okay today I'm going to talk to you
about standard form I'm gonna say why we
use standard form and how to use
standard form to show really big numbers
and really small numbers okay so first
of all standard form it's just used as a
kind of shorthand way of writing either
very very big numbers or extremely small
numbers and in science we come across
these kind of numbers quite a lot so
let's imagine first of all we're looking
at a very big number so for example
let's imagine we're looking at the
distance from Earth to the Sun now this
distance in meters is this here 1 4 9 6
0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 so that is how far in
meters it is from Earth to the Sun now
often when we're dealing with space for
example we're dealing with extremely
large numbers because space is enormous
ly well things in space are very very
far away from us so the reason why I'd
want to write standard form is if all
the time I've got to write out long
numbers like this it's more difficult to
read and it takes a long time it's
time-consuming so we use something
called standard form now standard form
always has the same the same pattern we
always have something point something
something times 10 to the something now
that might not make too much sense now
but hopefully it will do in a minute so
we look at this number the bits that
we're interested in is that there's the
information at the beginning of the
number so if it's something point
something something I know I'm going to
be looking at the first 3 digits so 1 4
& 9 so they're going to go here in a
minute
however we need to round this number as
well because 6 is above 5 this 9 is
going to round up rather than down so
instead this is going to be 1.50 times
10 to the something because I'm just
looking at the start of this number here
now to figure out what number goes here
I need to think how far this decimal
point moves so let's imagine it starts
off there just as it would do for this
number here it's gonna move 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 places because it's gone all
the way from hit until the end right
here so the answer is 1.50 times 10 to
the 11 meters because I've just that's
how far I can move the decimal point so
that's how we use standard form to look
up very big numbers let's imagine we
were looking at an extremely small
number instead because you can also use
standard form for small numbers so let's
imagine this time it was the size of a
virus so in biology you might be looking
at the size of a virus now let's say
this virus was this millimeters big 0.02
80 3 4 5 6 1 2 5 meters again the reason
why we want to show it in the standard
form is because if we're dealing with
viruses or bacteria instead of having to
write out these long strings of zeros
every time we could just write it kind
of shorthand way by showing it a
standard form so again it saves time and
it's actually easier to read once we get
used to standard form so we've got the
same kind of format this time we have
something point something something
times 10 to the something now because
it's a tiny number the big difference is
we're going to have a minus number here
and I'll show you what I mean in a
minute so this time rather than starting
right over here because all of these
numbers are zeros what we do is we start
here and we move this way until we find
our first nonzero number which is this
one here so this is going to be my start
right here the 3 digit so I'm going to
include is going to be this one this one
and this one so in this case so I'll go
all the way here my first digit is 1.2
five times ten to the something now
again let's put in where our decimal
point would be and now we need to move
it now instead of moving this way the
decimal point is going to go this way
and that's why we have a minus power
here so it's going to go one two three
four five six seven so this one is one
point two five times ten to the minus
seven
so just to recap standard forms just a
way of showing either very big or very
small numbers in a shorthand way we
always have the same format of something
point something something times 10 to
the something it's a very big number
this power is going to be positive and
it's going to be just the number of
times the decimal planes moves if it's a
very small number this this numbers
going to be negative and it's going to
be the number of times the decimal place
moves that's how you standard form thank
you